مشروع والاول من نوعه في العالم لنقل
الكهرباء من الفضاء الى الارض عبر الالوح
الشمسيه حدثنا اكثر عن هذا المشروع اهميته
دكتور
يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم صباح الخير طبعا
الفكره انه راح يكون هناك مثل القمر صناعي
جيو ستيشنري يعني ثابت مع مدار الارض
وهذا القمر الصناعي وهو ليس قمر صناعي
باسلوب التقليدي انما همم
اجهزه تجمع اشعه الشمس
وحجمها اكبر من برج خليفه مرتين حجم هائل
جدا هذا فقط في القطر في القطر الدائري
للي يجمع الشمس تجمع اشعه الشمس ثم ترسلها
الى الارض عن طريق اشعه المايكرويف والى
نقطه محدده
مساحتها تقريبا خمسه كيلو متر بحيث ان
تجمع اشعه همم المايكرويف وتعطي طاقه
قدمها اثنين جيجا والذي يغذي تقريبا
مليون ونصف بيت طبعا على حسب البيوت
البريطانيه ولا اي ساعه على حسب البيوت
الموجوده
فقط نفهم همم تغطيه اليوم عندما بنحكي عن
الالواح الشمسيه المجمعه من الشمس من
الفضاء كم المده الزمنيه اللي ممكن انه
تغطيها لفتره من الزمن هذا الشمس الماخوذه
من الفضاء
وايضا المساحه الجغرافيه التي يمكن ان
تغطيها
طبعا احنا نعرف انه عندنا مشكله المشكله
ان النصف الوقت عاده للالواح الشمسيه اللي
موجوده على الارض ظلام الليل فلذلك لا
تجمع الضوء بينما اللي موجود في السماء
اللي راح يكون في في القضاء الخارجي لن
تحده اي مشاكل لا غيوم ولا نهار عفوا
الليل فلذلك سيجمع اشعه الشمس باستمرار
وتظل هذه الاشعه موجهه تماما الى الارض
على مساحه تقريبا خمسه كيلو متر مربع